with the playground feature
you can explore protein sequences with
ai models trained on billions of
amino acids in minutes we use
transformers
state-of-the-art machine learning models
that are trained on most of the protein
sequences found in nature
both those we have assessed
experimentally and those that still have
to be studied
they can help uncover promising new
insights from amino acid sequences
let's see how it works
the playground can be accessed by
selecting the appropriate tab on the
upper right corner of the screen
the playground allows you to explore
either custom new sequences
or ones from the polypeptides present in
your active design
let's first look at one of the defense
and chains in the uploaded structure
as we can see the model returns an
estimated distribution of amino acid
probabilities at each position
however the colors or probabilities are
not particularly well defined
as the sequence is rather short and
could go anyway
we do see though that the cysteines
which are essential for the stability of
the protein
have a visibly higher probability than
other residues
to see more biologically meaningful
results we need to check out the full
sequence of the gene product
before it gets modified in the organism
here i have retrieved the full sequence
of human defensing from uniprot so let's
apply the model to it
and then we hit the submit new sequence
button
now the probability landscape is much
cleaner
we can see that there is a strong signal
from the n-terminal methionine
then in the beginning we see that the
model wants to put a string of leucine's
hydrophobic helix forming residues there
this is the signal peptide which
dictates where the protein will go
it should be indeed hydrophobic and
helix forming
interestingly at position 2 we see a
strong preference for arginine or lysine
both positively charged residues due to
positive inside rule
these are obligatory at the beginning of
a signal peptide
following the signal peptide we see a
pro-peptide sequence
which has no functional constraints and
as such
seems to have mostly stereochemical ones
such as proline in position 21
we see that the pro peptide sequence is
strongly biased towards negatively
charged amino acids
aspartic acid and glutamic acid these
are here to stabilize positively charged
mature defensing when it assembles
notably
we see that cysteines important for
stability of the cleave defensin
still remain highly favorable for each
position in the sequence
we have the presence probability of each
of the 20 natural amino acids displayed
as a heat map
it can also be visualized as a bar plot
another way to leverage the power of
these language models is with our
sequence generation tool
by selecting one or more positions in
the sequence as mutable
we can then generate most probable
variants
this slider here allows me to adjust the
number of generated sequences
that's it we've seen how to get insights
on protein sequences
using state-of-the-art machine learning
models and deep chains playground
thank you for watching and enjoy deep
chain